His name is
Ernst Brentwhistle.
Tech billionaire
and covert arms dealer.
And we have one shot
to bring him in,
and you two are
the best of the best.
Your codenames for this op
are Cross Bolt
and Butter Face.
Cross Bolt,
you're my point man.
I need you to take out the
guards and acquire the target.
Now, we want him alive
if possible,
but you are a go to
use lethal force if necessary.
Butter Face, you're running
a classic distract and capture.
You'll have a chance meeting
with Brentwhistle
when you run into him
at the party he's having
in his hotel.
On it.
Arouse his interest, take him
back to his penthouse,
and that's when you'll get
started making dinner for him.
Make him a casserole,
a meatloaf, your call.
Something with a protein
and a vegetable.
Don't go crazy,
cook something you know.
That's when I poison him,
right, sir?
Slow down, Butter Face.
Cross Bolt, while Butter Face
has him distracted
in the kitchen, you'll
rappel down the building
into the living room and
that's where you'll find
the hard drive.
Sweet.
It will be sweet.
Rappelling is awesome.
Butter Face, when you are sure
that Cross Bolt has the drive,
I want you to lure him
into the bedroom
and you are a go to
give him a blowjob.
Uh, sir?
I'm capable of hacking
into the mainframe
of a nuclear submarine.
We don't need
anything that drastic,
the blowjob
will do just fine.
Now we'll--
I'm sorry, I'm just--
I'm not sure I'm comfortable
with this, sir.
Don't worry.
There'll be plenty
of hidden cameras.
We will be right there
with you the whole time.
Literally, the entire agency
will be watching.
My dad works here.
Come on,
you can do this.
Shut up, Dennis.
All right,
under the table,
you'll find a duffel
and in it,
your specialized equipment.
Laser nunchakus.
There's just a scrunchie
in here.
That's to hold your hair back,
and remember, no teeth.
All right, team, let's go.
Operation Enduring Mouth
begins now.
( Amy )
Amy One, clear.
♪♪
Ow.
Cross Bolt, on behalf of
a grateful nation,
I present you with the highest
top secret award in existence.
The titanium star.
Butter Face...
feel free to keep
that scrunchie.
Hey, maybe next time
you could do a cool mission
like I just did.
Get your--
Fucking...
Bitch.